nein stopp und gegenstopp stopp stopp
stopp christoph wir machen hatte
behinderte hauptgericht mit einem
herzanfall einfach so und er trifft mich
einfach nicht so behindert stopp knopf
scharf luca toni am schlechtesten und
stelle mich einfach hallo ich meine
lieben freund und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren mine plex runde und zwar
spielen wäre
caption spielen deathmatch team
deathmatch und zwar habt ihr eine klasse
ihr weht da schon und ich bin ja zum
beispiel im team rot alleine und satan
jetzt mit christoph im team blau und wir
müssen uns jetzt gegenseitig bekämpfen
einfach wir müssen uns einfach die welt
zu töten
okay okay ja das ist gut ich weiß nicht
ob es gerade capture the flag oder
dragon age ist eine nomination auf jeden
fall oder das ist doch der manager okay
gut dafür dass manchmal die karte wein
geändert dass die hätten bei domenech
nur dieser eine karte ja okay dann ist
es dominieren
wir müssen durch die profitieren von den
anderen wahllokal ein
doch die wir sterben du bist einfach
sterben lassen es eigentlich sterben
einfach sterben wirst du ganz einfach
noch einmal dann einfach noch eine so
ist das nun mal locker ich habe zwei
getötet und ich hab das ja noch ein
genommen wissen steht da ich bin gar
nicht im blau gerade noch so die ganze
ich bin ihm bla bla bla was bringt leute
wieder wasser wasserstoff werfer zu
bringen
du kannst dir was bringt mir das ich
weiß nicht was es bringt scheiße ich bin
so wasser
was bringt das scheiße ich weiß nicht
ich glaube dass ich ein recht
interessantes spiel da sieht man wieder
dass ist die hauptschlagader gebende der
hauptstadt geben dass killer an einem
team bin weil ich bin in rot und direkt
rot führt hier ok blau wird gleich
führen aber wie so viele blaue
meinetwegen wieso das denn du hast
bekommst
wir sind erst diesen morgen wo an roter
noch nach osten eingenommen
günter h du stirbst jetzt so ist das
gerät soll ich einfach schon mit dem
trauma team anzeigt doch die polizei was
ist besser sondern einen posten
verteidigen oder noch ein bisschen
rumlaufen paar leute boxen und so keine
ahnung junge designer aus dem blau weiße
team mit mir machen für behinderte jetzt
kommt es darauf an und ich treffe
einfach nie kenne diesen bug wenn ich
etwas ganz drauf schreibt uns bisschen
dick fehlt
nein ich habe nicht mehr viel muss ich
passen online der blauen dahinter mit
meinen team kameraden getötet so wenn du
das jetzt ein nehmen willst da unten
dann werde ich aber da rein fischen naja
ich finde das ganz okay wir waren stopp
stopp stopp stopp tritt wir machen hatte
behinderte mann mit einem herz an nur
noch einfach so junge und er trifft mich
einfach nie weißt du du bist echt zu
behindern
stockstadt luca toni am schlecht design
und dann stelle ich einfach ich hatte
auch mal gerne leben mehr junge bleiben
ist es jetzt nicht begriffen lieber das
hinter dir ein team das hinter dir ein
das ist besser ich schwöre ich welche
von anderen seite ankommen werden
richtig boxen mit erdogan vor lukas
scheiße was ist das denn
lukas w
los gehts doch jetzt geburtstag feiert
diesen op günstig ein schlimmer fehler
ja ich solle lieber dass hinter mir eine
als ich doch der eine steht und warum
sie doch zu zweit auf mich das
eigentlich für baba wieder hat der junge
wieso hat er seine yaman tröstung
september war der diamant rüstung was
das für eine klasse keine ahnung hat
aber den post noch ja man ist so mega
schnell alles was ist gut für eine
klasse digger geil programme einzige bei
uns ja das spielprinzip verstanden und
immer super flaggen einem dann machen
wir einfach nichts
das kenne ich irgendwoher christo hinten
ich warte ich hab gesagt bekam ich das
hin
da kommt einer wie ein ast
so ist das nun mal luca wie schnell ist
der ich kenne keine kompromisse ein
handicap ich mache bestimmt keinen
frieden mit dir wenn du einem anderen
team bist
was sollen das wiso verliert damit blut
das kann die vereine nicht ob sie die
ganze zeit etwas wie tank also was ist
schwer
ich hatte da reisen schwert ja aber so
ist das nun mal luca ich nehme es wieder
leid
das wird eine kleine fonds gegen nicht
einfach hinten hier noch posten haben
wir alle oder was auch wenn alle wissen
dass ich besser bin als drucker kommt
irgendwo hinkommt einfach weil es ja
besser was löst ole reform spricht hier
noch mal okay davon leben ja dann kannst
du wieder ne nicht einhalten der anderen
kann sich wieder dürfen
ich kann auch so komm her einzelkampf
einwände weil die aus der baseballs
läuft ganz links da komme ich dort auf
mich zugelaufen
hey da wirst du gar nicht klüger auch
ohne wind bringen das ich schwöre du
bist wieder bei der base und nimmst dir
ein
hey was laberst du ich hab den nächsten
posten
noch ist also ist es noch mal war die
gerechte strafe
ich komme wieder hier bleibt da bleibt
da bleibt einfach da jetzt sollen dass
die kommen einfach schon auf uns drauf
ist so ist das normal dass wir wirklich
im spiel sind okay aber jetzt geht also
ich bin der scaler fragen so ist er
stets 63 ich steh 5 1 gewinnen
ich soll doch nur max davon muss ich
erstmal andere wohl nein ich verstecke
mich hinter lukas twickler wieder da
den leben das auf jeden fall ich nicht
wer sie bekämpfen richtig so wenn ich so
kein leben hat es einfach drauf gehen
ich hatte auch noch ganz ganz wenig es
mag nur zwei häuser mit einer so feuer
bibelstudium was ist das das richtig ok
ok kann da nichts ging machen so ist
wirklich so wer ist denn die klasse geht
also 2000 nicht drauf sind tot
er hat mir das nicht ich hab ich doch
getötet euch beide so gearbeitet war der
andere nicht tun
ich hab mir gar nicht mitgeholfen weißt
wer durch alleine einfach zeit gewusst
hätten
also ich bin ich bin immer besser im pvp
gefasst und luca ist einfach so er
verliert vier runden gegen mich gegen
ist leicht da aktive types kinderalter
solchen ganzen sache nicht das heißt ja
nicht dass killer der macht mir so der
innenminister der style der stelle
jetzt hoffen wieder nach dahinten jetzt
halten wie die beiden positionen junger
roth holt auf alte malz niemals alleine
zu zweit können die richtige opfer seit
dem schreiben wieder den kräften ist
eine ecke rum und wartet damit zu dritt
christoph war doch gleich ein ganzes
team
ich denke es hat da einfach nur
christoph brum und kennt aber es ist
einfach drei leute aus dem team zu dem
posten
goldener pflug aber ihr kaltes verreisen
kann egal wo ich wirklich besiegen doch
dauerbrenner irgendwie auf einmal ich
brenne ich ja sag ich doch ich bin
mental auch mit wasser kann man sich so
vom brennen befreien löschen
hallo da kommst du zwei zeige dass es so
viel das ist so feige das ist so
unglaublich feige ist ja erstaunlich
sowohl durch feige bekommen wir das in
weckern ihr können ihm nur zu zweit an
die kommen nur zu zweit an das ist dass
darüber kann man nicht mal stolz sein
heißt sich kommt alleine hin und igel
oft einfach zu zweit also also ich mich
also ich bin stolz drauf
ich konnte einfach zu zweit weiß ich
selber wird aus zwei kommt jetzt auch
nicht ja aber ihr seid zu dritt sogar
diesmal was soll man machen wenn ihr zu
dritt seit das richtig ja er steht
einfach in unserer paybox dunst dass auf
jeden fall ist jetzt nicht gerade beim
in die klasse auszuwählen christoph
kommen einfach zu unserer base hin
ja ich schon jetzt komm ich vermisse ich
mal das spiel ist nomination nicht so in
die base rennen gehen und die direkt
beim spot installieren
wir zeigen dass wir besser sind warten
wie viel aus meinem team ich bin damit
sehe ja ich und zwei andere
das coole an uns einfach nur den
gefahren der sonne richtig richtig
witzige runde auf jeden fall ich alleine
gegen fünf leute die spaß gemacht vor
allem in die fünf leute denken sie in
die allerbesten infiziert noch einen
drauf gehen lassen auf jeden fall
richtig gefallen hat ich halte die
daumen hoch da lassen morgen kommt noch
eine folge irgendwas anderes bei stani
und dann